well starting on sunday if you live in
the las vegas inside the city limits
you can now get alcohol from restaurants
and convenience stores
delivered right to your front door eight
news now reporter kate houston working
on the story today she went to michiwa
khan mestra
mexican restaurant which is out in the
northwest part of the valley
to see how this will help their business
we pride ourselves on you know the best
margaritas in las vegas
kyle vannucchi is the general manager at
michoacan gourmet mexican restaurant on
centennial center
and tropical parkway starting this
weekend las vegas businesses that sell
alcohol like michoacan
as well as third party delivery
companies will be able to deliver
alcohol to city residents before
customers had to come in person to pick
up their alcohol
and now this actually gives them
opportunities to stay home the new law
passed by the las vegas city council
hopes to give restaurants and
convenience stores a needed boost after
months of restrictions
we're very excited and pleased that
we're able to
to do this and it's going to you know
hopefully help out liquor sales a lot
more
going forward and hopefully we can get
back to a full capacity here pretty soon
before deliveries can begin businesses
will need a license to sell
alcoholic beverages for off-premise
consumption as well as an additional
license unique to this law
delivery services will also need to
apply for the license once approved
bottled liquor beer and wine will be
available for delivery to anywhere in
the city
except on non-restricted gaming
properties for months michoacan has
provided make your own cocktail kits for
customers
so they anticipate this will be a smooth
transition if we can bring that home to
you without having to come inside our
restaurant that
is a huge plus for us and the customer
protocols must be in place to ensure
delivery drivers are 21
or older and have gone through alcohol
awareness training
kate houston 8 news now
all right so this new law again only
applies to businesses and residents who
live within the las vegas
city limits unincorporated clark county
north las vegas and henderson they all
have their own rules and regulations